we are old coin miners so we don't mind
Bitcoin but we mind just about every
other coin besides Bitcoin you have to
go through to the next room the bunker
we've got a lot of noise in there and a
lot of airflow mine step here are our
primary mining rigs we've got a mixture
of some nine card rigs and some twelve
card rigs all of these are ten eight 2ti
and video cards and they're all
constantly changing which algorithm that
the mining depending on which one is
most profitable at any given time and
here is our original money Rick this is
our testbench
a bit flash here and that's just because
those particular cards happen to be
cheaper at the time of purchase on the
mining rigs now instead of having a
motherboard with two or three PCIe lanes
with 16 slots on you will have card with
maybe 12 different connectors for
graphics cards because graphics cards
are quite large and don't all fit on
white make stitches on the board you
will move them away from each other
using a writer card and an extension
cable and you can see quite a lot of
that going on in the back there looks a
bit of a mess but it is functional and
of course if you can get a bit farther
apart you can put a lot more air through
keep the heat down we've got heat wave
going on in the UK people may not know
this but for us this is very hot at the
moment yeah the heat wave hasn't helped
a lot and I'm pulling solution that we
did originally put in hasn't really
covered on these we've actually had to
start run from the power back while
we're developing a new cooling solution
it's gonna be a very make to cooling
solution and I'm gonna buy an
off-the-shelf one so we'll be buying car
radiator fans and then using the
Raspberry Pi to control the speed of
those depending on the temperature I
know it's a bit of a contentious issue
mining and energy but can you talk me
through that and it's a slightly
different with altcoins is that right it
depends on the coin and each coin has
wider one algorithm or multiple
algorithms and each of those algorithms
requires a different amount of power to
compute some of the algorithms are
really heavy on GPU core some of them
are very heavy on the memory usage when
algorithms that we use all vary so we
don't really have a specific efficiency
on any one of them that we can set up at
the moment each of these cards do 250
watts of electricity in and converting
majority of that to heat so we've got
essentially a 15-kilowatt Peter and have
quite a small room so we need to just
keep that air moving as much as possible
what's going on with the software you
mentioned it switches between coins I
mean how does that happen is that
something above the shelf is that
software you guys have written so it you
can make yourself but we've used an
off-the-shelf format for that particular
job
puts up to several different websites
one of them is what to mind calm and
that tells you using your efficiency of
your card versus the difficulty of that
particular point at the moment what your
returns are going to be
and it can compare all of those very
very quickly and select the right point
to mine at the time in terms of old
coins is there a kind of standard amount
or is it waiting for the jackpot that
one Golden Nugget how does it work it's
exactly the same as Bitcoin but the
difficulty level is much lower so you
don't have to use ASIC machines
specifically the mining it some of the
old coins have got an ASIC algorithm
built in and the idea there is keep it
as decentralized as possible so if it's
just a six then only those people with
an ASIC and larger vessel in Asics are
going to be able to really contribute
towards the system and if it's just GPUs
then there's still an ASIC market there
that you could expand into and keep it
as decentralized as possible and theirs
is to be the ethos of the coin whether
they decided to go fully decentralized
or slightly less decentralize if you
heard different graphics cards with
different hardware say like an AMD
or Nvidia then yes definitely they'll be
doing different coins simultaneously but
with all of these being exactly the same
card essentially if it's most profitable
for one it will be most profitable for
all of mine so here's your 1x risers
those are 12 PCIe connectors we're going
to normally see them be this full size
here the 16x connector which is what the
graphics card plugs into yeah and then
these are the same slot but they're only
running at 1x speed you gotta need the
full width of there you don't like the
actual data transmission is relatively
low
it's too high and them quite amount of
number crunching and then it returns
with a very small value essentially yes
or no I found something that goes back
to the pool and the pool confirms
whether or not that's a valid solution I
highly recommend the six card
rigged for anybody's home and any room
you put six card rigged in during the
winter you won't have to pay for heating
on the output it's hot air lots and lots
of Hayase if you can find a use for that
higher it's no longer really being
wasted so perhaps it could turn it into
a good use join the winter and certainly
during our office moves we couldn't run
these rigs at the offices so I took one
home my colleague took one home to keep
it going over and my conservatory was
warmed all through the winter I didn't
have to turn my space heaters on to keep
that nice and toasty so the rig paid for
its own electricity it paid a monetary
reward as far as Bitcoin is concerned
and it paid from heating so I could turn
the heating off so I've certainly
recommend having one at home
and as soon as it went the wife my
where's that mining rig back it's too
cold in here I need it back now people
will be used to seeing a silver
backplate where you screw it into the
back of the PC it's got a mesh over it
so it slows air flow and we've got
nothing to screw that into in our mining
rigs so we take it off just drops a
couple of degrees off the temperature
every law helps when it comes to getting
heat out here people on the other side
of that camera can't understand the
temperature we are planning on upgrading
the cooling solution the summer that
we're having this year wasn't on our
cards so the extra 15 Celsius that the
ambient temp
sure is now is actually causing there's
problems and we've got a new set car
fans behind this that will be building
into a new cooling system so this was
our first build rig we've got a spare
cabinet sitting around we thought would
be pretty good for airflow that's
primarily what they're designed for as
you can see we've worked a few baffles
in cardboard and a bit of rock wool
there that makes a big difference the
amount of air that's being forced
between the cards the air comes in the
bottom and pulled up by this power
radiator fan at the top and when this is
running it's pretty much close to
ambient temperature at all time even
with that many GPUs in presume these car
fans are relatively inexpensive compared
to this wine they're being used because
they're super cheap super cheap pretty
high throw throughput easy to power I
mean it's in the car has got very
similar power supply to in a PC running
only 12 volts yeah they are not the best
cars for minding every coin by any
stretch of the imagination but they are
probably the best cars for mining most
of the coins the boards are actually
mining mining motherboards but they
would work absolutely fine as a gaming
rig